es la primera prueba dio negativo pero
la primera prueba está muy cerca de
aquel contacto que tuvo con gustavo
béliz en términos temporales entonces
para asegurarse de que no haya sido un
falso negativo va a haber otra nueva
prueba en unos días me preguntabas antes
si no te había dicho cuáles son las
reacciones y las críticas el tema es que
el presidente alberto fernández viene
insistiendo en todas sus alocuciones
públicas en la importancia del cuidado
para la población de mantener distancia
de no reunirse de usar barbijo
cubrebocas entonces cuando se supo esta
noticia se vio esa foto de esa cena el
domingo aparecieron voces críticas
diciendo porque aquí en la población en
general porque el presidente nos pide a
nosotros que nos cuidemos y en no sé
cuidar esa crítica se va a seguir
escuchando y se escuchó en ocasiones
anteriores cuando se difundieron
imágenes e informaciones de reuniones
similares que el presidente mantuvo en
otras ocasiones y además por supuesto
por el cuidado que debe tener un primer
mandatario de su salud para no ponerse
en riesgo claro la exposición es un poco
inevitable en algunos casos pero lo que
le pide la población es que se cuide
tanto o por lo menos casi como le pide
al resto de los argentinos